aiutiamo le persone a vivere il viaggio
come un momento di crescita e
ispirazione di terapia per l'anima per
farlo le mettiamo in connessione con chi
possa essere d'aiuto in questo cammino
alla ricerca della felicità vorrei che
vi concentrasse su queste due parole
felicità e connessione
uno dei mali del nostro tempo e che
continuiamo a cercarle all'esterno la
felicità nel vestito nuovo nell'ultimo
modello di iphone nel cane nei gatti che
sembrano essere gli unici a capirci nei
figli che crediamo debbano essere una
nostra emanazione cerchiamo di sentirci
più vicini agli altri attraverso un iper
connessione che può rischiare però di
renderci più frammentati
continuiamo insomma a riproporre la
mentalità
se avessi sarei ma così facendo non
otterremo altro che l'antitesi della
felicità rimanendo sono più soli e vuoti
occorre quindi ribaltare completamente
il paradigma
e per farlo noi crediamo che la chiave
sia
avere delle relazioni sociali positive a
guardarci anche attraverso gli occhi
degli altri può aiutarci in questo
percorso alla ricerca della felicità non
è un caso che appunto ricerca della
felicità alla mano e la qualità delle
nostre relazioni sociali
risulti essere proprio un fattore
predominante nel determinarla quindi io
le persone con cui lavoro ci siamo
appunti chiassi quale potesse essere
questa chiave per creare connessioni
positive tra le persone affinché si
potesse trasformare il sempre più
diffuso senso di solitudine infelicità
la risposta che ci siamo dati è viaggio
il gadget fatto da sempre
lo strumento più potente che abbiamo a
nostra disposizione per entrare in
connessione con gli altri però negli
ultimi anni ha sempre preso più le forme
dell'intrattenimento e meno della
formazione e questo ha fatto sì che ci
concentrassimo più sulla meta e non sul
perché profondo che ci spingeva a
partire quindi occorre nuovamente
cambiare paradigma e destinazione umana
si inserisce proprio in questo contesto
ribaltando completamente la concezione
del viaggio infatti a chi sta per
partire non chiediamo tanto dove vuole
andare bensì chi desidera conoscere
siamo infatti il primo e unico tour
operator al mondo che propone viaggi
ispirazionale
selezionando e raccontando realtà
turistiche sconosciute ai più ma
interessanti per chi vede il viaggio
come incontro raccontiamo insomma storie
di persone che vale la pena conoscere e
che possano essere le risposte per le
domande che il viaggiatore si sta
ponendo perché è vero che non troveremo
mai le risposte al nostro esterno se non
aspiriamo con le domande giuste quindi
navigando in internet nei principali
portali di viaggio che conosciamo tutti
ci imbattiamo nelle solite domande
quando volete partire dove volete andare
con quale mezzo volete spostarvi su
destinazione umana troverete tutto un
altro genere di domande
quindi chi volete conoscere appunto
perché state partendo qual è il perché
profondo che vi sta spingendo a partire
che tipo di ispirazione state cercando
ma anche che esperienza volete vivere
nella struttura che andrete a scegliere
le nostre strutture appunto qui nelle
destinazioni umane non sono raccontate
non sono divise per area geografica
almeno non solo ma sono divise appunto
per ispirazioni le ispirazioni che
abbiamo scelte sono
44 sulla base di quello che secondo noi
il viaggiatore di oggi sta cercando e
cosa cerca
soprattutto cerca cambiamento possono
essere scelte di vita
radicali quindi proprio il classico
mondo tutte cambio vita ma anche
semplicemente
una strada nuova
cerca ruralità quindi immersione nella
natura siamo ormai abituati a vivere
tutti in contesti urbani anche molto
inquinate abbiamo bisogno di immergerci
nella nella coralità magari anche di
sporcarci le mani nella terra
cerca innovazione sia un'idea innovativa
imprenditoriale per la mente magari
cerca un viaggio dove possa conoscere
qualcuno che lo aiuti a svilupparla e
cerca spiritualità come vi dicevo
all'inizio siamo confusi spesso ci
sentiamo soli e frastornati e ci
sentiamo anche un po perse abbiamo
bisogno di ritrovarci magari di farlo
con qualcuno che possa guidarci in
questo percorso
insomma nelle nostre destinazioni umane
che sono in tutta italia dalle langhe a
pantelleria troverete non solo delle
ispirazioni e quindi persone che vi
ispirano ma potrete vivere delle vere e
proprie esperienze immersive in cui
mettervi alla prova
vi racconto qualche esempio appunto sul
cambiamento il classico mollo tutto
cambio vita per un agriturismo ma sarà
davvero pane per i vostri denti ad
esempio da paola dell'agriturismo ca del
buco potrete vivere per qualche giorno
come un host e capire se questo vostro
sogno è realizzabile o è semplicemente
un utopia
e poi abbiamo andrea federica qua gioco
in caso il podere san giuliano di
bologna loro metteranno mettono a
disposizione dei dei viaggiatori che li
vanno a trovare la loro esperienza ormai
decennale
nella realizzazione di una delle aziende
agrituristiche più innovative d'italia
quindi ho un'azienda agricola magari
tradizionale voglio innovarla voglio
confrontarmi con qualcuno che puo
aiutarmi in questo dà loro posso farlo
infine gli adorabili andrea patrizia di
del sasso erminia bed and breakfast
sulle colline della val marecchia il
loro motto è facciamo l'amore con la
natura quindi da loro potrete ad esempio
semplicemente fare semplice in realtà
non lo è ritrovare il tempo di vivere
magari facendo una camminata sulle sulle
loro colline o anche immergendovi nella
loro vasca riscaldata legna sotto le
stelle della della valmarecchia
insomma è chiaro che siamo nell'era del
turismo esperienziale non siamo gli
unici a dirlo anche tripadvisor
attraverso questa ricerca del 2014 tre
barometer ce lo conferma nel 71 per
cento degli intervistati dichiara
infatti di voler partire per allargare i
propri orizzonti il 62 per cento perché
alla ricerca di un senso di libertà il
47 per cento per un arricchimento
culturale e sempre il 47 per cento
perché vuole migliorare i propri
rapporti sociali
il viaggio sta quindi tornando ad essere
ad assumere nuovamente il suo senso più
tradizionale cioè le persone partono
perché cercano non soltanto una meta non
soltanto un luogo ma anche una crescita
che sia sia personale che professionale
l'innovazione sta nell'interpretare
questo bisogno proponendogli quello che
è davvero un nuovo viaggio di formazione
non voglio però che intendiate il
viaggio di formazione come un qualcosa
di noioso che prescinda
dall'intrattenimento e dalla parte
emozionale non è così il punto è che
siamo individui felici solo nei momenti
in cui ci sentiamo realizzati in tutte
le sfere della nostra vita che sono il
lavoro svago e la famiglia
serve quindi coerenza tra queste tra
sfere altrimenti rischieremo una corsa
frenetica per rubare del tempo all'una
piuttosto che all'altra senza in realtà
a trovare mai tempo per nulla
l'individuo se ci pensate che è davvero
che raggiunge da avere il successo non è
necessariamente solo colui che sa
l'individuo che è successo è colui che
mette in coscienza e che quindi affianca
alla conoscenza l'esperienza è per
questo che su destinazione umana non
proponiamo solo delle idee che
potrebbero apparire anche effimere ma
mettiamo il viaggiatore alla prova
attraverso delle vere e proprie
esperienze che gli consentano di
radicare quello è che ha imparato
durante quel viaggio
l'individuo che è successo è quindi una
persona che fa essere qui ed ora che
riesce ad essere un tutt'uno con quello
che sta facendo solo se riusciremo a
fare questo costruiremo davvero una
nuova era felice è un nuovo futuro è per
questo che diciamo che destinazione
umana non è un qualcosa di esternano e
destinazione umano e siamo tutti noi è
il nostro interrogarci è il nostro
metterci in discussione è il nostro
essere affamati di idee e una giornata
come oggi lo dimostra
destinazione umana e quindi il nuovo
viaggio che parte dall uomo e arriva
all'uomo perché crediamo che la vera
felicità non sia realizzabile mai
completamente da soli parte da una
nostra ricerca individuale passa
attraverso connessioni positive con gli
altri per tornare nuovamente a noi è
solamente più evoluti e d'altronde è il
viaggio è la metafora della vita e la
vita stessa il più grande viaggio quindi
non limitiamoci ad attraversarla
indossando tante maschere diverse ma
viviamo la pieno avendo il coraggio e
l'innovazione di essere semplicemente
noi stessi quindi vi auguro buon viaggio
a tutti